Angelo you talked about having 200 plus
hours of footage so what were some of
the deciding factors when you handed it
over to that editor you've added a
slight bit of your own story in which I
feel really sets off the film nicely
what were your thoughts on cutting
certain parts out your back and forth
with the editor had it all that work the
first cat was very difficult because I
want I was so hands-on and I wanted
certain things there was so many in so
many interviews and things that I wanted
to keep and so it was just a process i
had another editor come in he got
finally a picture that I wanted and then
I went back to my first out of Matthew
Jones when I decided to pull it off the
shelf again and and we talked very
candidly about what because we started
it together and he saw the set the this
version and he goes I really like all of
the black-and-white footage and how we
kind of put the older family components
together and and then something he said
he goes well I don't know how are you
going to feel about this and I really
think we should do there was one scene
that he thought we should take out and I
said you know what I'm ready to just let
it go i'm going to trust you and that's
what has been happening with this
project that I've had great people on
board and Matthew was just one blessing
so he took it and he made it to what we
have today and and I was so blown away
what he did because from the very first
ideas I had in 2006 i think it was when
we started this he got all of it into 66
minutes
Wow so it was a part of me that had to
let go of the hard drive I was holding
on to it it's my baby great good you
know so do you feel that that message to
other filmmakers that have some amount
of control in the beginning and then at
some point find someone you really trust
and relinquish all that yeah i think i
think it's i think that was a really
good turning point for me I've like I
had to I had to like you know really
shake him up I said come on please just
work on this movie but I knew I could
trust him I knew I could I knew I could
get what I was looking for and he was
going to be the doing he was going to be
the guy you know he was the guy his
nickname is Picasso on the film you know
and as a filmmaker you're right i would
i would suggest that you know if you're
really close to the project step away as
much as you can and trust the process
you